this one's like a little actress right
you little actress yeah she's not afraid
of the stage definitely she's a little
talented girl right here
becoming a model now you're just fine
with an agency yes yes
how do you like it
them so it's like very I I wanted to go
in the route of not knowing someone
everybody's like oh you know someone in
Hollywood you know a friend you should
you know it's that's the easy route I
really wanted to go buy the book you
know I really wanted her to audition
so I don't know if you know this or
people out there that you have to
audition to be an agency okay so they
have to be accepted and so she
auditioned for a prestigious agency
called Zuri and she got in and yeah we
just started we've been uh you know
auditioned for Sesame Street and all
that good stuff so you never know what
might come through what's your what's
your favorite show that you would want
to be on oh that's a good question
that's hard
she probably wants it being like a movie
Scream or something like that yeah
she likes um horror movies right
she's believe me she watches those
slasher movies yeah she knows it's fake
what's the other one it's
oh it you want to be in it
you want to be in it yeah that's the
scariest movie ever oh my God
[Music]
she's got a really really crazy scream I
have to say she does this like fake
scream inside the car when um ice is
driving all the time and it blows his
eardrums out he's like oh you're gonna
do something with that scream one day
girl yes yes how is it being a momager
like managing
nice and her more than me you know I
kind of I kind of stepped up a little
bit and started doing a little bit more
social media but I'm like having more
fun with her
how do you describe today how do you
feel
um actually I feel way more amazing than
I think that he does I
um I don't know I just get excited over
the little things so that if this is a
big thing can you imagine how excited I
am Ice is very cool and chill and he's
like whatever about everything but
Chanel and I were up really early this
morning excited for Daddy right
we wanted to see the star take a picture
with it but you know this is so well
deserved he needs this you know it's
long overdue to tell you the truth
people don't see the hours and hours
that he works you know on film off film
in the recording studio
um I mean he spends more time out of the
house you know than kind of like you
know with his family because he really
really needs that the fans and the
outside world like he needs them to know
that he loves them right you know and we
love daddy right yeah yes so I think
someday you're gonna have a star on the
Walk of Fame are you going to
foreign